les curtuces collages ces fameux gâteaux
cheminés au cœur de la cuisine de rue
hongroise sont devenues tendances sur
les réseaux sociaux et dans plusieurs
grandes villes dans le monde comme nous
le raconte Élise
[Musique]
mabetalise dans les gâteaux cheminées le
nom en hongrois c'est que je colère on
roulement
cake curtches ça décrit une cheminée
puis collatch ça veut dire plus comme
brioche puisque la pâte est très
similaire un pain brioché
cependant un voyage en Transylvanie que
ce jeune entrepreneur d'origine
hongroise a eu l'idée d'amener les
gâteaux cheminés au Québec on a fait ça
un gâteau cheminée parce que après la
cuisson comme l'enlève des moules en
bois le gâteau puisqu'il est vide à
l'intérieur ça va fumer telle une
cheminée
ça nous a pris environ trois quatre mois
pour vraiment perfectionner personnalisé
aussi un peu la recette avec les
connaissances de ma mère et de ma
grand-mère qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
son commerce à pignon sur rue à Montréal
il nous explique les différentes étapes
de préparation des curtaches selon le
mot choisi ils peuvent être de forme
cylindrique ou coniques et c'est quoi la
première étape on commence par quoi on a
deux étapes de lever pour cette
pâtisserie là je dirais que c'est
vraiment le point le plus important dans
toute le processus parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on va avoir notre texture
moelleuse à l'intérieur ça nous dit les
secrets les ingrédients secrets de ta
part qu'est-ce qui a contient vraiment
super
du beurre beaucoup de gens qui rentrent
dans notre local nous disent aussi que
ça sent le citron parce que on y met du
vrai zeste de citron dans la pâte
donc la première étape on va huiler un
peu les bâtons on va prendre notre boule
de pâte qui est déjà levure pour la
première fois on va la faire en bande de
pâte qu'on va pouvoir faire la suite
rouler sur le bâton on commence au bout
du bâton on fait un tour et pas plus
compliqué que ça et on la met en dessous
de la bande de porte à la fin
et on va écraser la pâte pour fermer les
petits espaces entre les bords
et finalement on va apposer une dernière
petite couche d'huile sur laquelle le
sucre va coller par la suite
donc maintenant c'est à ton tour
d'essayer alors je te laisse
et on roule exactement
[Musique]
tu vois un petit peu plus mince
tu fais le tour
cette seconde aussi
le Curto chocolat a plusieurs centaines
d'années autrefois il était réservé à
l'élite mais il s'est répandu dans la
population
du charbon même aujourd'hui on va
retrouver le charbon principalement dans
les petites cabanes extérieures pendant
les marchés de Noël en Transylvanie en
Hongrie très populaire aussi en
République tchèque à Prague donc ça a
commencé comme ça depuis par la suite ça
du coup propagé avec les marchés de Noël
on aime les curtoches pas juste en
Europe de l'Est sur les réseaux sociaux
il suscite un engouement partout dans le
monde en Europe en Asie et en Amérique
du Nord
je pense que on aime partager les choses
qui ont l'air cool les 14 sont en train
de faire des entreprises et beaucoup de
personnes veulent partager les photos
les vidéos des cartons à Instagram
Tic-Toc les choses comme ça
[Musique]
mais ils sont différents pour les
clients aussi au Canada
les gâteaux cheminés ne sont pas encore
très connus au Québec mais il gagne en
popularité ailleurs au Canada la chaîne
Eva the original basé à Toronto a des
succursales dans plusieurs provinces
nous avons 6 deux internautes ont un
nouvel école deux amis se sont ici à
Toronto
le Tommy le sucre et la prochaine étape
faire cuire faire cuire la pâte c'est
vraiment des machines spécialisées qui
vont tourner la porte pour cuire la
porte de l'intérieur mais en même temps
de faire caraméliser le sucre à
l'extérieur
beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est une
pâtisserie frite mais en fait non c'est
cuit donc c'est vraiment notre grand
avantage par rapport aux autres desserts
qu'on connaît déjà une fois le sucre
caramélisé on peut coller différentes
garnitures comme de la noix de Grenoble
des noisettes de la cannelle et du sucre
ou de la noix de coco
et l'un des moules
et ça va se dérouler
un petit peu voir comme ça
résultat une pâtisserie moelleuse à
l'intérieur et croustillante à
l'extérieur
les curtoches collatch peuvent même se
décliner en version salée un peu comme
des sandwichs l'été la version conique
garnie de crème glacée est très
populaire nous étions le premier au
Canada de faire les chemises le plus
populaire pour notre client c'est notre
Dream qu'on avec square chocolat caramel
et
saveur de gâteau au fromage Oreo
tiramisu Machia tarte aux pommes les
possibilités sont infinies et décadentes
David nous prépare son compte classique
donc on va commencer avec un compte
canal et sucre ensuite on va badigeonner
l'intérieur du Nutella on va y rajouter
des fraises et bananes avec la crème
glacée à la vanille sur le dessus finale
de fraises et voilà
[Musique]